ah here we go again against mr.
williger's yeah okay I just play this
game and see what happens I mean okay
what is he doing actually I think I
against the Kings Indian is playing them
the exchange variation so i won't i
won't allow that so easily get him near
his desired boring endgame so quickly
okay it's not particularly great but it
does exchange stuff which is what he
wants it is not any good because white
has more space and shouldn't trade but
he's trading everything anyway in every
position he will also trade queens now
it's just better to play Queen a form
but you would probably take anyway it's
just what he does or queen III maybe he
will play the better move no of course
not okay so what am I going to do here
f6 or 95 I don't know it's it's really
not much happening
try to be quicker just completely equal
I mean like completely um no
yeah I'm ahead of the clocker that's not
that's not bad they're putting those on
dark squares
okay so let's not blunder some stuff
here go to g6 I've been quick here right
that's not bad
if anybody is a little bit better and
this end game is actually like but it's
still nothing nothing serious in
particular i can i can try to claim that
it's nice for me that I have a pawn on
c4 which is in a light square them but
it's nothing serious at all it's just
equal nothing going on dead whatever
okay so we put something more on a light
square what would I exactly she going to
play night to a forum or what I don't
know
playing Bishop e6 possibly next really
and I don't really get that
yeah well one problem against him is
that he's a good end game player and
sometimes he just shuffles without any
purpose just to play on time but
sometimes he just plays good moves and
you have to kind of be very alert that
that when he does play the good moves
you are you are ready to respond
correctly and not do anything anything
stupid and I'm not sure if this is maybe
one of the cases of a good move
b7 hangs
I've check here now this is interesting
you can also play Bishop b3 ham ok i'm
not sure i'm at times ticking down we
should be seventh King c7 as a double
attack so that's not going to work check
Kim I'm not sure I can i play for with
him can i play for win yet somehow i
don't know i would like to but I'm not
not sure if I have some game drive okay
there's already three times and maybe I
had some chances there I don't know it
looks this look strange it is this night
a 4 looked strange to me but maybe it's
not so bad para compass on 0000 time now
it's sadly probably it's just it shows
equal and he has no real alternative
there if he tries to do this i have not
be five it's just completely dead this
this whole position all the time but I
wanted to be quick there and not lose on
time so it's not very exciting but what
can you do it's very difficult against
him because he just treats everything
yeah even if it's completely Bob bad
yeah 95 for example net is debatable but
you you wouldn't really normally trade
all those pieces here I am and
especially not guindy aid but he just
wants to trade everything it's just
better to play the Queen to f4 to e3 and
keep a bit of more pressure on but you
will trade everything and always go for
the simplified position so at least I
was was quick that didn't didn't spend
much time ok not very exciting but it's
a dis the draw thanks for watching